the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
a prediction video today I want to talk
about the lovable sore Davos Seaworth
also known as The Onion Knight to be
honest with you I don't think I have
ever made a standalone video about this
character now I know many of you have
requested a video about Davos in the
past but I don't have a definitive
answer for his end game it's hard for me
to say what Davos will actually do next
season but I guess I can throw out a few
possibilities I did go back and look at
a bunch of his scenes just to see if
there was any foreshadowing and I did
notice a few things that may or may not
have some significance to them so that's
what I want to discuss today as of right
now Davos should be on his way to white
Harbor with John Daenerys and the rest
of their entourage we know that John and
Daenerys want to arrive in Winterfell
together that way everyone in the north
can see them as allies now what Davos
does from here until the end of the
season is a bit of a mystery but I
suspect he will continue to serve Jon
Snow when I went back and checked out
some of Davos his old scenes I couldn't
help but wonder if they were trying to
foreshadow Davos eventually serving Jon
Snow
once upon a time back in the third
season Davos was locked in a Cell on
Dragonstone during that time Princess
Shireen started to visit sir Davos
because well we all know they had a very
close relationship almost like a father
and daughter relationship some of you
may remember the scene when princess
Shireen snuck down into the cells to pay
Davos a visit she wanted to bring him
something to read so he wasn't down
there bored to death but the only
problem was Davos did not know how to
read princess Shireen does offer to
teach Davos how to read then she
continues to tell him about the book
that she brought him then she proceeds
to teach Davos how to read the very
first word can any of you guess what
that word was let's take a look at what
she said I'll teach you I'll come when
Bert's on duty it's easy
it'll be fun rule
we can't why not what would they do
focus in sells Illinois to Scott at the
beginning this foot is ekam you see a E
and G now I'm sure some of you might say
that scene doesn't mean anything at all
but I think it was interesting that the
very first word Davos learned how to
read was a GaN a couple years after
learning that word Davos would not only
meet a different angle on targaryen but
he would basically end up as hand to the
king to another a GaN or at least for a
very short period of time until John
bent the knee to Daenerys but all of
that could change once again when it is
revealed that John is actually Aegon
Targaryen the heir to the Iron Throne
this revelation will probably blow Davos
his mind along with everyone else's but
why else would a vos be kept around for
so long unless he had a very big part to
play in the end Davos quickly became Jon
Snow's right-hand man but what else
could he do besides give counsel and
help bring people to their side
something else might have been revealed
and another one at Davos is scenes this
time he was when Melisandre and Stannis
this was shortly after Davos assisted
ginjury in escaping from Dragonstone
before Melisandre could sacrifice him
obviously that upset Stannis because he
was dead set on letting Melisandre carry
out that sacrifice Davos got right in
the way of their plans so Stannis
actually ordered Davos to be killed
that's when Davos pulled out a letter
from Castle black in the letter it said
the army of the Dead was coming sooner
than later this got Stannis and
Melisandre attention the true war lies
to the north my king
des marches on the wall you need someone
to rebuild your army for you someone to
convince this Lord of that law to fight
for you to bring sell sort and pirates
to your site I've made my decision
he's right you need him he has a part to
play in the war to go as you can see
Stannis now knew that he had to set his
sights in another location
if the army of the Dead was truly coming
south to kill them all then stain as a
new that he had to go north as soon as
possible
Melisandre made it known the War of the
five kings meant nothing the true battle
would take place in the north what they
said in that scene could have an impact
on the final season Melisandre told
Stannis not to kill Davos because they
did need him according to Melisandre
Davos has a part to play in the great
war but what could she possibly mean by
that he's right you need him he has a
part to play
he's the devil
he'd been saved by that fire god you
like tomorrow
how can Davos help them defeat the army
of the Dead
we have heard Eva's say countless times
that he's not a fighter so what else can
he do and how would you get him to
King's Landing
I can smoke again but if the gold cloaks
would have recognized you I'm warning
you
I'm not a fighter since Davos isn't a
very good fighter maybe he can put his
other good skills to use during that
scene with Stannis and Melisandre Davo
said something that may come true during
the final season Davos told Stannis you
need someone to help rebuild your army
you need someone to help convince the
different Lords to fight for you but
then he said you need someone to help
bring the sell swords and pirates to
your side now we have already seen Davos
do almost all of this for Jon Snow the
only thing we haven't seen Davos do for
Jon is go get him some sell swords and
pirates well there just so happens to be
20,000 sell swords on their way to
Westeros as we speak the golden company
are on their way and as I have said in
other videos almost everyone thinks the
golden company will switch sides if that
does happen then perhaps Davos has
something to do with it Davos already
needs something to do next season and he
is the perfect man for that type of job
not only is Davos extremely persuasive
when he speaks but he also knows his way
around the waters depending on what
happens when you're on Greyjoy's fleet
the golden company may need a ride to
the north if the golden company do
abandon Cersei then perhaps Davos is
sent to go pick them up
or maybe Davos can even smuggle himself
into the city again in order to talk to
the commander of the golden company
Davos has the ability to talk to someone
into fighting for John's cause we have
seen him talk the iron bank into
learning Stannis money and we have even
seen him talk Lyanna Mormont into
helping Jon and Sansa since Davos may
not do much fighting next season this
would give him something else to do that
way he's not sitting on the sidelines
now let's move on to something a little
darker when Melisandre said Davos still
had a part to play in the great war
against the army of the Dead maybe it
has something to do with her - as we all
know Davos does not like Melisandre at
all even though she technically did save
Davos his life when Stannis wanted to
kill him
you could say Melisandre did save Davos
in that scene but what she did to
princess Shireen is unforgivable and
this is something Davos will never
forget the last time we saw Melisandre
was when she was talking to Varys on
Dragonstone
she told Varys she was heading to
volantis but then she would return to
Westeros one last time she also said
that she will die in Westeros
there is no way that happens without us
getting to see it ever since we have all
seen that scene the big question has
been how would Melisandre die next
season
some people say Jon Snow will kill her
and some people say Arya Stark will kill
her because according to Melisandre she
said they would meet again but what
about Davos we do know that Davos has
one of her dead for a very long time he
tried to kill her after the Battle of
Blackwater Bay but some as Stannis's men
did stop him however we all remember
what Davos said to Melisandre right
before she left Winterfell when she
finally had to answer for the murder of
princess Shireen Jon told her to never
return to the north or he whatever
hanged as a murderer right south today
if you return to the north I'll have you
hanged as a murderer if you ever come
back this way I will execute you myself
in my opinion there is only one other
reason why Melisandre would come back to
Westeros she has been telling us about
the darkness coming to smother Westeros
ever since she was introduced she knows
this is why she is here she has her own
part to play and as I've shown you in
other videos she has also told Jon Snow
that she can help him defeat the night
King now Davos and Melisandre have been
connected ever since they were both
introduced based on what they've said
during some of their scenes maybe their
fates are connected as well Melisandre
said Davos had a part to play and
Melisandre said she would be coming back
to Westeros where she would also die
both of these things will happen in the
final season so perhaps they both happen
at the same time Melisandre has always
said a great gift requires a great
sacrifice a great gift requires a great
sacrifice
if Melisandre truly wants to help them
defeat the night king then she may just
have to sacrifice herself in order for
them to do so and I am sure Davos would
love to carry out that sentence
now do I actually think Davos will be
the one to kill her no not really
because as I have said in other videos I
think jon is the one to kill her
but I can't deny the possibility of
Davos getting the job done like I said
at the beginning of the video Davos is
hard to predict he could try to get the
golden company on their side or he could
go pick them up with Dany ships and then
of course he could have something to do
what Melisandre is endgame since those
two characters have been always
connected in some way when it's all said
and done I think Davos does survive all
of the events to come if Jon Snow
survives and does become the king of
Westeros than I imagine Davos would
continue to be his right-hand man
but if Daenerys takes the Iron Throne or
if they decide to break the power up
then I imagine Davos would be given some
land of his own I think he does deserve
his own castle in my opinion anyways I
just thought I would take some time to
discuss our old friends sir Davos
Seaworth The Onion Knight before I go I
do have a small announcement to make as
I'm sure most of you know by now the
author of Game of Thrones did release a
new book about the history
the Targaryen fire and blood came out a
few days ago and I ended up buying two
copies of the book I am given the second
copy away so if you would like to enter
for a chance to win the book there is a
link in the description of the video I'm
sure a lot of you already bought a copy
the day it was released but there may be
some people out there that might not be
able to get one right away
so this giveaway would be perfect for
you good luck to those of you that enter
and thank you all for watching the video
I appreciate that as always I hope
everyone has a good day I will see you
again very soon
[Music]
[Music]
you